-Democrats will retain
control of the Senate
after news organizations
projected wins
for Democratic candidates
in Nevada and Arizona,
defying all the predictions
of a red wave
and humiliating Republicans,
especially Donald Trump,
who has been having
a full-blown meltdown
Now that Republicans are
turning on him and blaming him
for their party's
catastrophic performance.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
I don't have to tell you that
going into these midterms,
Republicans were very confident.
They predicted a red wave
that would hand them
control of both
the House and Senate
and deliver a strong repudiation
of Joe Biden's presidency.
Some even went further
in predicting a red wave
and said it would be
much bigger than that.
-Look, I think we're going
to see a wave election.
I think it's going
to be a tsunami.
-Hot just a wave,
but a red tsunami.
-We're not just going
to see a red wave,
we're going to see
a red tsunami.
We're not just going
to see a red wave.
We're going to see a tsunami.
-[ As Cruz ]
"It won't just be a red wave.
It'll be a red tsunami.
In fact, it'll be a red monsoon
combined with a red hurricane
and a red cyclone that hovers
over the Pacific Ocean,
sucking red sharks
out of the water
and dumping them
all over America
in what can only be described
as a red sharknado."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Although I will say,
Ted Cruz
does have the facial hair
of a guy who's been stranded
on a desert island
after getting caught
in a tsunami.
It looks like he's starring in
a direct-to-video remake
of "Castaway,"
except in Cruz's version,
Wilson kills himself
after a week.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Cruz ]
"I didn't need you, Wilson."
I got to say, it never gets old
watching Ted Cruz
get absolutely humiliated.
The only person who loves it
more than I do might be,
I don't know, Ted Cruz?
It's clearly his calling
in life and he's so good at it.
Donald Trump spent
his entire presidency
trying to get Congress
to pay for his stupid wall.
They could have raised
that money in one day
if they just made Ted Cruz
sit in a dunk tank.
Do you know how much
they could have brought?
There would have been
enough money left over
for a second, smaller wall
to make sure nobody [bleep]
with the first wall.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, while Cruz
was confidently
predicting a red tsunami,
his Senate counterpart,
Florida Senator Rick Scott,
who was in charge of taking back
the Senate for Republicans,
was getting even more specific,
claiming Republicans
could end up with
as many as 55 seats
after all was said and done,
and even named specific states
where he thought Republicans
could upset Democrats.
-There's every reason to believe
that we're going to pick up
at least one,
but I think we can pick up
four or five seats this year.
If you're Republican,
you want to be a U.S. senator
and you want to try to change
the direction of the country,
this is the year
you want to run.
Herschel Walker has already
beaten Warnock
in Georgia, in the polls.
Adam Laxalt's already ahead of
Cortez Masto
by four points in Nevada.
We will beat Kelly in Arizona.
I think we'll win New Hampshire.
-Am I crazy to think
that the Republicans could
win a Senate seat
in Vermont in 2022?
-You're not crazy.
-You know, if you really want
to know
whether or not you're crazy,
maybe don't ask Rick Scott.
"If you ask me, all of you
Earth people are crazy."
[ Laughter ]
Also, just in general, when you
start a sentence with
"Am I crazy?" on Fox News,
the answer is almost always yes.
It would make a great title
for most of their shows.
Although in fairness,
saying the words "I am crazy"
is a pretty good indication
that you are,
no matter where you say it.
For example, right now there are
a bunch of Jets fans
sitting around saying,
"Am I crazy or are we going to
win the Super Bowl this year?"
And look, the Jets are good.
I'm not denying that.
But that doesn't mean
they're not still the Jets.
I said as much to our security
guard, Jim, this morning,
and then he told me
that NBC has a new policy
where talent has to
ride to work in the trunk.
And he also told me "I need to
keep my [bleep] mouth shut,
desk boy."
I think he's sensitive
because he already
bought tickets to the Super Bowl
and the green and white
face paint.
[ Laughter ]
Which is an unprofessional thing
to wear to work,
but obviously...
[Quietly]
I'm not gonna tell him that!
Anyway, as you probably
know by now,
none of those predictions
came true.
Republicans lost all of those
races except for Georgia,
where the race will head to
a runoff after Herschel Walker
finished second
behind Raphael Warnock.
And now Republicans
have also lost the race
for control of the Senate
after news organizations
projected Democratic wins
in the key states
of Arizona and then Nevada.
-Fox News alert, the Democrats
will maintain control
of the Senate.
The Fox News Decision Desk has
called Nevada's nail-biting
Senate race in favor of
incumbent Democrat
Catherine Cortez Masto
over Republican challenger
Adam Laxalt.
That gives the Democrats
the 50 seats
they need to retain
the majority control.
-What? But the space lizard
and his Sasquatch friend
told me there
would be a red tsunami.
[ Laughter ]
But man, for the news to come
from Fox of all places --
they're the ones who told us
there'd be a red wave
in the first place.
This is like your weatherman
telling you
it's going to rain all weekend,
and then after you cancel
all your plans,
tells you it's actually
75 and sunny,
so fold up those umbrellas,
or if you don't know how,
just leave it at the top of the
stairs like an insane person.
"Am I crazy or can I just
leave this on the steps?"
You guys remember that?
That's what we here at
"Late Night" call a classic vid.
-Classic Vid!
[ Airhorns sounding ]
-Do we have to put the stamp
over my face?
The vid's there.
[ Laughter ]
Man, I really hope Republicans
weren't watching Fox News
on Saturday
when that call happened.
Of course, that's impossible.
If you know
any Fox News viewers,
they're always
watching Fox News.
One time, I visited my grandma
and the only way to get her
to stop watching Fox News
was to change her channel
on her old-ass TV
with a pair of pliers
and then bury the remote
in the backyard.
Oh, but she was wily.
She was out there
all night digging holes,
looking for that remote.
When my grandpa saw her
digging a hole out the window
"in the backyard, he said,
Oh, it's not all bad.
Now we have someplace
to bury her."
[ Laughter ]
That story's not true.
Every one of my grandparents
is long dead.
[ Laughter ]
So Democrats have defied
the odds and defied history
to produce one of the
best midterm performances
for the party in power
in political history.
And now that reality has set in,
Republicans are furiously
pointing fingers at each other,
looking for someone to blame.
And honestly,
it is kind of fun to watch.
-Donald Trump kept saying,
"We're going to be winning
so much,
we'll get tired of winning."
I'm tired of losing.
I mean, that's all he's done.
-Donald Trump cost us
the president--
and the Senate twice in a row.
-Our voters didn't show up.
We didn't get the voters.
It's a complete disappointment.
-We're not a cult.
-We're not like, okay,
there's one person
who leads our party.
-If the voters conclude
that you're putting your own ego
or your own grudges ahead
of what's good for the country,
they're going to look elsewhere.
-Trump is the past.
-Let's not vote Mitch McConnell
into leadership.
He doesn't deserve
to be majority leader
or minority leader.
-Josh Hawley tweeted last night,
"The old party is dead.
Time to bury it.
Build something new."
-McConnell spent close
to $400 million
on these Senate candidates.
I don't know what goes on
behind the scenes,
but that is a lot of money,
and we didn't pick up
a single seat?
So either some of
these candidates are garbage
or the money's
not being well-spent.
-Oh, I know. It's both.
You spend your money poorly
and you spent it on garbage.
Don't feel bad about it.
We've all done it before.
Lord knows I've taken an Ambien
and gone on eBay,
and three days later
I get a package
with a baseball signed by
Lou Gehrig's friend, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
Ol' sweet Kevin.
Alabama Congressman Mo Brooks,
who was once a huge
Trump supporter
and even spoke at
the Capitol on January 6th
called Trump
"dishonest, disloyal,
incompetent and crude,"
which is true,
but Trump didn't prove
that last week.
It's just last week,
there were consequences.
It's like your nephew
telling you today
he has doubts
about the future of crypto,
when you definitely remember
this was his profile picture
last month.
Really looking forward to seeing
you at Thanksgiving, Kyle.
I'm guessing this year,
you're not gonna tell me
it's a shame NBC pays me
in American dollars.
[ Laughter ]
Kyle's a lot.
Still,
it's so great to watch these
[bleep] turn on each other
like a bunch of roommates
who got a pet cougar
and now they're all like,
"Has anyone seen Dave?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, just a quick aside,
my favorite part
of that montage came next,
when Fox host Jesse Watters
wondered what happened
to all the money
Donald Trump raised.
-Trump's sitting on a massive
war chest in Mar-a-Lago.
Where'd that money go?
We don't know.
-No, I think we all know.
It's in his giant coat.
"Hey, Mr. Trump,
we can't find all the money
you raised for GOP candidates."
"Well, best of luck
in your search.
I'm gonna go out for a walk."
"In that coat?
It's like, 95 degrees."
"But the weather can turn.
So I'm going to keep
the coat on,
because I misplaced my umbrella
four years ago."
Now, obviously,
these results have been
especially
devastating for Trump,
whose hand-picked
election denier candidates
lost all across the country.
And Trump was banking
on a huge sweep
for his clown car
of bozos and freaks
so they could help him
win back power.
Mo Brooks said
earlier this year
that "Trump had repeatedly
and recently raised the idea
of attempting to rescind
the 2020 election results
and reinstall him
as president.
It was a stunning allegation
that would show Trump
not only attempted
to subvert the 2020 election
while in office, but that
he is extracting promises
from allies to try again
if they take power in 2023."
Trump actually thought
that was possible.
How does he think
that would work?
Does he just think
Congress can pass a bill
that says Joe Biden has to leave
and then Joe would just do that?
Because if we have learned
anything about Biden
from these midterm results,
it's that he's much savvier
than he appears.
We said this last week.
We'll say it again.
Biden's Mr. Magoo bit
where he forgets where he is
or what he's doing might just be
an act to cover for the fact
that he's actually
a political mastermind.
If Trump actually tried
to have Biden
removed from the White House,
Biden would probably
do something like pretend
to get stuck on stage
or, you know, trip on the stairs
three times in a row.
And then he'd say
something like,
"Excuse me, Donald,
could you help me up?
I'm a frail old man."
And then as soon as Trump
gives his hand to Biden,
Biden would grab him by the arm
and just
throw him over his shoulder,
put him in a headlock and say,
"I'm going to fold you like
an umbrella, bitch!"
Now...
predictably, with
the GOP turning on him,
Trump is lashing out with
a series of absolutely insane
and typo-riddled
social media posts.
Trump has been
attacking fellow Republicans
like Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis,
claiming the election
was stolen
and even insisting that
there should be a do-over.
-Former President Trump
is already laying
into Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis,
as it becomes possible,
the two men may face off
in a 2024 GOP primary,
Trump posting to his
Truth Social platform,
claiming it was he who saved
DeSantis' campaign in 2017
and accusing him
of lacking loyalty and class.
-Trump also weighed in
on the midterm results
on his Truth Social website --
in one post, he claimed New
Hampshire's Republican
Senate nominee lost his race
for not staying strong
and true about the Big Lie.
-He said that because Arizona
is likely to
still be counting
at the end of the week,
that must mean they want
more time to cheat.
-Trump took to
Truth Social with a tirade,
writing in part,
"They stole the electron
from Blake Masters."
He he wrote the word "electron,"
as in a subatomic particle.
Adding,
"Do election over again!"
Exclamation point.
-How is it possible
that he typed
"electron" instead of
"election"?
I would say that maybe
Trump got screwed
by autocorrect on that one,
but then, is it really possible
that Trump's autocorrect hasn't
learned the word "election"?
It's literally all
he tweets about --
not tweets, whatever they
call them on Truth Social --
bloops, bleeps, derps?
May I suggest brain farts?
I think that would be better
than saying "a post."
Just imagine Wolf Blitzer
saying,
"The former president
with a new brain fart
on Truth Social,
claiming the electron
has been rigged."
Whatever, I'm shocked Trump
is capable of
spelling the word
"electron" even by accident,
since there's no way
he knows what it is.
"We all love --
We all love electron,
don't we, folks?
He's the bad guy
from the Avengers movies, right?
'The Rise of Electron.'
One of my favorite of all --
of all the ages,
was the Age of Electron."
Trump is reportedly
on the verge of announcing
that he'll run for president
again in 2024,
but Republicans are
already turning on him
and turning on each other.
Voters rejected Trumpism
and the MAGA movement yet again,
just as they did
in 2018 and 2020,
and now Democrats
have defied history
and will control the Senate for
the rest of Biden's first term.
Trump is probably at home right
now trying to psych himself up,
staring in the mirror, telling
himself over and over again...
-You're not crazy.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪